[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y de France
24 esta semana ponemos los focos en
Centroamérica para preguntarnos si la
tendencia autoritaria va ganando terreno
lo hacemos a partir de ejemplos
concretos pero como siempre iremos de lo
general a lo concreto en un camino de
ida y vuelta para ello nos acompañan
cuatro invitados en este estudio que les
paso a presentar ya Gil batallones
director de estudios en la escuela de
altos estudios sociales en Francia
sociólogo e historiador de las formas
políticas en Latinoamérica bienvenido
Jill mucho gusto Pascal Duo analista y
corresponsal del diario de hoy
bienvenido Pascal Muchas gracias
y Daniel Vázquez doctorante del Centro
Nacional de investigaciones
especializado en política hondureña
bienvenido gracias por la invitación
también nos acompaña a distancia la
politóloga Kendra Carrión docente de la
Universidad iberoamericana de México su
tema de tesis es el desmoronamiento del
Estado de derecho en Nicaragua
bienvenida Kendra Buenos días Muchas
gracias por la invitación es un gusto
para mí estar aquí
autoritarismo en Centroamérica o en
nuestro asunto en Primera Plana
[Música]
Bueno hoy partimos de una imagen que sin
duda ha impactado al mundo
una puesta en escena impresionante las
cámaras enfocan a centenares de hombres
que vestidos con hombre con ropa
interior Blanca abandonan las cárceles
del Salvador para ser trasladados hasta
el proyecto insignia de la política de
seguridad del presidente nayib bukele el
centro de confinamiento del terrorismo
un enorme complejo Presidiario una
demostración de poder frente a las maras
y aquí lo complejo de la cuestión las
críticas de organizaciones humanitarias
se juntan con el aplauso de una mayoría
de salvadoreños que llevan muchos años
soportando inseguridad vamos a tratar
esa Espinosa relación entre
autoritarismo Y popularidad a partir del
caso ya no solo de bukele la Democracia
pasa por horas bajas en Centroamérica
autocracias crimen organizado y
violaciones de Derechos Humanos
caracterizan a los líderes de una región
con un pasado marcado en sangre por las
dictaduras repasemos algunas portadas el
New York Times afirman este artículo que
el presidente del Salvador
erosiona los derechos a cambio de
combatir el crimen y se pregunta si su
fórmula está funcionando la prensa por
agua saca en portada las fotos de
desterrados políticos de por parte del
régimen de Ortega 222 desterrados a los
que ha quitado la nacionalidad El
Heraldo nos muestra otro caso el de
Honduras donde se amplía hasta el 6 de
abril el estado de excepción para frenar
La ola de violencia y extorsión bueno
son muchos los ejemplos como estamos
viendo que nos brinda la actualidad para
hablar de esta cuestión que le planteo
genérico los autoritarismos vuelven a
marcar el paso en Centroamérica los
autoritarismos vuelven a marcar el paso
en Centroamérica pero pienso que no son
los autoritarismos de antes es decir que
los mismos de antes Tenían un proyecto
de desarrollo estabilizador y digamos el
autoritarismo del partido militar en El
Salvador del partido conciliación
nacional o de los partidos militares en
Guatemala o el somocismo tenían algo que
querían imitar el pri mexicano y el
desarrollo estabilizador hoy en día las
élites políticas están conectadas con el
narcotráfico y están con ganemos lo más
que podemos y poco nos importa el
régimen político y callamos a toda
oposición y hay una manera de nepotismo
que parece como un regreso en el siglo
XXI en las dictaduras de final del 19 y
de principios del 20 el caso de los
presos de bukele Pascal impactado al
mundo por la puesta en escena y nos
remita esa Espinosa cuestión de relación
entre autoritarismo y popularidad Qué
pasa cuando se plebiscita el hecho de
saltarse los Derechos Humanos para
convertir al crimen usaste la palabra
que ilustra esa situación la complejidad
sí El Salvador tenía una tasa de
homicidios en 2015 de 100 por 100.000
habitantes era el país más peligroso más
mortal hoy en día es cierto esa política
securitaria que era la prioridad de
nayib bukele que fue elegido en primera
vuelta en 2019
da resultados claro y obviamente esos
resultados y las imágenes que vemos
ilustran la fuerza tanto del peligro
tanto de la vida cotidiana difícil que
vivieron los salvadoreños como la
respuesta porque ahí habrá una respuesta
a medio
media central frente a esa urgencia y
ahí es el tema complejo darle respuesta
incluso éticamente porque es un poco
Snoop desde otras partes desde Europa
criticarlo sin empatizar con el
sufrimiento es muy muy complejo
Exactamente
eso se inscribe en una etapa nueva ya no
estamos en el este oeste Centroamérica
fue durante años y diseños un foco
encendido del enlace este oeste que
podía explicar una forma de
autoritarismo en los 70-80 ya estamos en
otro otra etapa y en una región
fragmentada Daniel hablaba allí de
autoritarismo Sí pero distintos no sé si
también lo podemos ver en el caso de
Honduras lo que podemos observar en
Honduras es que saliendo de un gobierno
autoritario como fue el del juego
Orlando Hernández que se encuentra
extraditado en Estados Unidos a la
espera de su juicio por nexo con el
narcotráfico
de alguna manera su popularidad es lo
que explica la llegada del gobierno de
Xiomara pero este gobierno en lo que se
ha dedicado durante ese primer año es en
replicar las políticas de sus
antecesores Buscando el control de todos
los poderes del estado por ejemplo en el
caso del poder legislativo
ellos han impuesto a un incondicional de
la pareja presidencial sin seguir el
debido proceso y por medio de
negociaciones y acuerdos bajo la mesa
con el partido liberal y el Partido
Nacional Celaya también ha logrado
imponer a la presidenta de la Corte
Suprema de Justicia que también tiene
lazos de parentesco con la familia
presidencial Entonces definitivamente
estamos también frente al auge de un
poder dinástico lazos de parentesco
luego vamos a hablar de ello pero antes
si me permiten Voy a preguntarle a
Kendra Carrión politóloga y docente de
la Universidad iberoamericana de México
su tema de tesis es el desmoronamiento
del Estado de derecho Nicaragua luego
los voy a preguntar si Nicaragua todavía
era un paso más para allá Ahora más que
nunca el régimen de Ortega Murillo
parece afianzado y toda posibilidad de
oposición pues ha sido reprimida
cualquier sanción o declaración han sido
en vano qué es lo que mantiene al
régimen Daniel Ortega es un actor
central de la política de Nicaragua y lo
ha sido por más de las últimas cuatro
décadas así incluso antes de llegar al
poder se aseguró el control partidista
de entidades clave como el poder
judicial así como la aprobación de
varias leyes a la medida que habilitaron
su regreso al poder parte fundamental de
la supervivencia del régimen han sido la
continuidad de la política económica
liberal de los gobiernos que precedieron
al de Ortega así a pesar de mantener una
retórica socialista Ortega mantuvo esta
política liberal económica y apalancó
sus programas sociales y redes
clientelares con el financiamiento de
fondos venezolanos lo cual de un lado
garantiza el financiamiento de entidades
como el fondo monetario internacional
entidad que en varias ocasiones ha y
aplaudido el manejo económico del
gobierno de Nicaragua Así mismo el
régimen sigue recibiendo fondos del
banco centroamericano de integración
económica el cual en los últimos días de
hecho ha recibido bastantes presiones
tanto medial del mediáticas como
académicas para dejar de financiar al
régimen autoritario por último Ortega
controla directamente los mandos de las
fuerzas del Estado así como su sucesión
con acceso Especialmente del ejército a
oportunidades de negocios que les han
convertido en un fuerte poder económico
con participación en rubros como
inversiones financieras el sector
inmobiliario bienes raíces industria
comercio y servicios existen mucha
especulación respecto a que la reciente
liberación de los más de 222 presos
políticos y su posterior destierro a
Estados Unidos se debió a presiones
provenientes del ejército con el fin de
evitar más sanciones sobre todo de
Estados Unidos hablamos del caso de
Nicaragua del caso de el caso del
Salvador Jill respecto quisiera comentar
algo más allá de las imágenes porque las
imágenes de los presos de los la gente
de las maras presas son sumamente
impactantes pero detrás de estas
imágenes hay pactos del gobierno con
líderes de las maras hay pactos del
gobierno con narcotraficantes el nombró
oficiales de policía altos responsables
con comprometidos con el narco como
Embajadores es decir que la política de
la mano dura es una simpática antipática
falsa es decir aparece como dicen los
mexicanos como el muy muy pero detrás de
la mesa pacta y de la misma manera
Nicaragua digamos con el destierro de
más de 200 prisioneros políticos entre
ellos figuras claves de la oposición es
un signo de la debilidad de Ortega y que
las sanciones que pegan digamos a las
fortunas mala vidas de responsables
sandinistas cercanos la familia Ortega
tienen un costo Y si los militares
quieren y pudieron ser uno de los que
quisieron la liberación de estos presos
es porque ellos tienen un fondo de
pensión en Estados Unidos y que pueden
Estados Unidos puede decidir investigar
el origen de los fondos de este fondo de
retiro y que probablemente hay dinero
mal habido entonces lo que hablamos es
de que se plebiscita la mano dura lo
cual me llegaba a preguntar a reflexión
que hace Gil Pascal o Daniel si creen
que de forma general el sufrimiento y la
violencia de los estados
Centroamericanos hacen que sus
ciudadanos acepten con más
condescendencia o sin tanto miramiento
la política de la mano dura creo primero
que es muy importante cuando hablamos de
Centroamérica introducir el concepto de
graduación porque hoy en día
Centroamérica a pesar del mecanismo de
integración del zika cuyo secretario
general es por cierto nicaragüense es
diversa hoy en día es fragmentada cada
país está confrontada a una situación
nacional única y en esa graduación no
podemos poner al mismo pie lo que
llamamos autoritarismo La dictadura
nicaragüense
y la situación en demás países hablamos
del triángulo Norte no habla Salvador
Guatemala Honduras pero también hace
parte de Centroamérica países como Costa
Rica Panamá que es verdad que no están
tan involucrados en de lo que hoy
estamos hablando
No es que no sean tan involucrados es
que no son involucrados es decir que los
bancos costarricenses y panameños
reciclen narco dólares lo hacen todos
los grandes bancos del mundo pero
digamos no hay una violencia que se
pueda comparar
en el tema de la integración porque el
zika Costa Rica y parte de sica
en eso Hay también una vía importante a
la cual debemos pensar si quizá la
cuestión Claro Nicaragua es el salto más
cualitativo como decía como decía Pascal
hay una graduación pero a lo mejor es
que hay otros resto hay un resto de
países algunos de ellos que se van
aproximando a ese modelo Pues
diríamos
en Centroamérica la temática hoy en día
que ha sido percibida como el eje
central es la seguridad y Ela seguridad
pública En unos países cuyos recursos
sacados de los impuestos obligan los
estados en concentrarse en unas
temáticas en unos sitios geográficos
está clarísimo en Guatemala por ejemplo
entonces ahí se agrega además esas
dificultades pero por cierto la
seguridad va a introducir a mediano
plazo los temas de justicia de impunidad
de corrupción todos estos temas que
venden ahora seguimos hablando de lo que
está diciendo Pascal voy a hacer una
breve pausa pero seguimos enseguida aquí
en Primera Plana hasta ahora Enlace del
cono Sur a Norteamérica de los Andes a
Centroamérica una cita semanal con los
temas más importantes de los países del
continente americano presentada por los
corresponsales de France 24
enlace en France 24 y France 24.com
seguimos en Primera Plana esta semana
analizando si hay una tendencia que se
expande autoritaria por toda
Centroamérica lo hacemos partiendo de
ejemplos concretos pero también trazando
pinceladas que
nos viene a mostrar una radiografía de
cómo está la región lo hacemos con
Pascal Batallón Daniel Vázquez y a
distancia con la politóloga Kendra
Carrión Daniel usted conoce bien el caso
de Honduras donde se acaba de ampliar el
estado de excepción para combatir la ola
de violencia como veíamos al principio
del programa
Xiomara Castro llegó al poder hace poco
más de un año prometiendo reformar un
estado corrompido por el narco tras la
etapa de Juan Orlando Hernández qué
balance podemos hacer de este año en qué
ha quedado todo aquello miren a nadie le
queda la duda que los hondureños
salieron a votar en noviembre de 2021
buscando una ruptura con el juego
blandismo no obstante lo que podemos ver
Es que el gobierno de Xiomara Castro se
inscribe perfectamente en la misma
lógicas de nepotismo de clientelismo que
caracterizaron a su antecesores
digamos que la estructura del estado se
conforma en base a las lealtades
al expresidente Celaya y a su esposa su
gabinete de gobierno se ha compuesto con
familiares y cercanos a la presidenta Y
es de notar que una de las primeras
medidas de este gobierno fue la
aprobación de un pacto de amnistía
política Buscando el perdón de que
aquellos funcionarios
envueltos en Casos de corrupción durante
la primera administración Celaya eso ha
dejado mucho que desear digamos entre la
opinión pública a la vez se ha
recompensado a las fuerzas armadas con
un aumento en su presupuesto anual a
expensas del gasto de salud y educación
que de hecho estos presupuestos nunca
son ejecutados en su totalidad Entonces
esto ha dejado mucho que desear
volviendo al caso de bukele es un
presidente joven que se ha presentado
como el ceo del Salvador y da golpes de
comunicación populistas adaptados sin
duda estos tiempos hablantes Gil de
autoritarismo Sí pero
transformados distintos esta sería la
adaptación al Siglo 21 de este tipo de
autoritarismos este tipo de personaje
como decía Pascal las situaciones son
muy diferentes porque digamos Yo pienso
que en Nicaragua no es solo el
desmontableamiento de un estado de
derecho y de un régimen democrático sino
la aparición de una tiradura con un
dictador de corte totalitario y nayib
bukele juega apuesta a los viejos trucos
del populismo y efectivamente con lo que
llamaba un analista francés
un autoritarismo milenio hay un
excelente artículo en nueva sociedad
sobre esto es decir que él usa todos los
métodos de la comunicación de internet
para vender una imagen de él que seduce
a la gente pero también no hay que
olvidar que hay una parte importantísima
de la población salvadoreña
probablemente más del quinto de la
población que vive fuera del país y que
hay en todos estos países de manera muy
paradójica movimientos democráticos de
voluntad de controlar los ejecutivos de
respecto al Estado de derecho de las
derecho de las minorías étnicas o otras
y al mismo tiempo una especie de va y
viene entre tendencias y tentativas
autoritarias o totalitarias de
dirigentes políticos y una sociedad que
maduró que tiene el sentido de tener
derechos a tener derechos y que hace la
situación sumamente conflictiva en todos
los países Pascal Bueno yo creo primero
hay que partir de
la luz Global en El Salvador en El
Salvador hubo desilusión no más se firmó
la paz en 92 Los acuerdos Chapultepec en
este ahí
de que se inscribía en el este oeste hay
hubo desilusión Porque todos han creído
en una visión liberada a nivel económico
en una alternancia hubo alternancia en
los treinta últimos años 20 últimos años
en El Salvador incluso llegó al poder el
fmln la ex guerrilla hubo presidentes
Pero qué pasó la corrupción la
corrupción Mauricio Funes está refugiado
desde 10 años en Managua después de
haber robado comprobado juzgado más de
300 millones de dólares entonces todo
eso es un punto común Aquí sí que
tenemos una una línea común en todos
estos casos y eso participó de una
desilusión Y se agregó en el caso de El
Salvador la temática seguridad con la
Isa política de deportación desde los 90
de deportación de marras que estaban en
los Estados Unidos y y que fueron
deportados devueltos a los países
originarios lo que creyó un sistema
Paralelo que tomó demasiado espacio
vamos a preguntar por corrupción y esas
familias no volvemos con Kendra Carrión
por otro lado hay docente en la
universidad iberoamericana de México
simplificando el panorama los Ortega se
apoyan en una práctica exacerbada del
nepotismo otros países de la zona parece
que siguen el mismo ejemplo como como
hablamos de Salvador con bukele quizá
también Honduras lo podemos hablar luego
con los castros Celaya es el caso el
régimen nicaragüense es más bien un
régimen autoritario de tipo personalista
por lo que a estas alturas sobre todo Ya
consolidada esta este control del poder
la cuestión familiar media mucho más que
la partidista de otro lado la familia
Ortega Murillo cuenta con más de 22
empresas privadas que de hecho la
consolidan como uno de los principales
grupos de económicos de Nicaragua a
pesar de todo esto me parece fundamental
subrayar a la audiencia que a lo largo
de la historia de Nicaragua el nepotismo
y el patrimonialismo han sido una
constante en la cual los intereses
privados de los gobernantes y el manejo
de los recursos públicos Se confunde la
supervivencia de la familia se liga a su
supervivencia en el poder y esto lo
vemos con cuestiones como la de Rosario
Murillo hace pocos meses de hecho se
anunció que Ortega buscará oficializar a
su esposa como copresidenta que nos
puede por supuesto indicar Hacia dónde
se direccionan los posibles planes de
sucesión pero esta no es la única gasta
o linaje que ha existido en Nicaragua a
lo largo de mi trabajo sobre Nicaragua
varias de mis Fuentes llegaron a
asegurarme que parte del proyecto de
Ortega era justamente consolidar a su
familia en uno de estos linajes
tradicionales del país centroamericano
objetivo que como se evidencia se ha
conseguido Daniel también podemos
extender el caso Honduras no con los
Castro Celaya bueno el partido de
libertad y refundación
desde su fundación se ha demostrado ser
un instrumento piramidal al servicio de
una figura caudiesca que es Manuel
Zelaya quien para muchos críticos es la
persona que mueve los cielos detrás del
Poder y
digamos que lo esencial en el caso de
Honduras es de tomar en cuenta esto
estos pactos y estas negociaciones que
se le haya logra con sus adversarios
mientras que su esposa está relegada al
plano protocolar no la semana pasada una
delegación de alto nivel encabezada por
Manuel Celaya visitó al presidente nayib
bukele elogiando esas políticas de
seguridad de las que hablamos pero es
importante notar que en el caso
hondureño No
no toma la misma dimensión y no ha dado
los mismos resultados no se hablan de
algunas centenas de detenciones mientras
que en El Salvador son decenas de miles
no y recuerdo con los periodistas
independientes como aquellos del medio
contracorriente no está dando los
resultados que se esperan consideran que
el nepotismo es moneda común en la
región Pascal Pues no sé si es una base
común existe
dependiendo de los países ahora está
clarísimo Nicaragua Pero Nicaragua
porque Daniel Ortega tiene una enorme
experiencia del Poder
recordémonos De quién eran los ochenta
de cómo sobrevivió a los 90 la
alternancia Violeta Chamorro presidenta
de Nicaragua en total sorpresa en
febrero del 90 y cómo logró llegar con
volver con una alianza con Arnoldo
alemán es decir que esa experiencia a
raíz de los años ha vuelto una
concretización Perfecta de Real de la
Real política y hoy en día él inventó un
nuevo concepto que es la esencia de la
perfección de la Real política es El
sinvergüenza me gustaría hablar también
de que rol juegan otros terceros países
en la región yo iba a ponerles El
ejemplo de Estados Unidos a partir de
Guatemala no que siempre siempre se
presenta como el socio más fiable pero
me decía allí que sobre todo Tenemos que
hablar del caso de China no y de
Venezuela digamos el el papel que jugó
la Venezuela de Chávez Para apoyar
Ortega y apoyar otros gobiernos como el
del fmln en El Salvador o el de Mel
Celaya en Honduras fue importantísimo y
digamos después de la caída de la
capacidad de actuar con la
digamos la banca rota de Venezuela el
gran actor que se perfila
geopolíticamente en América Latina no
solo en América Central es china por
ejemplo cuando la gente dice que el
proyecto del canal en Nicaragua es una
falacia no es una falacia si pensamos
dentro de cinco años si pensamos en los
proyectos de China de desarrollar su
Marina de rehabilitar el puerto de
Mariel en Cuba y de hacer pasar
containers por una vía oceánica que
controlarían ellos es el mismo proyecto
que el de los norteamericanos cuando se
construyó el canal de Panamá la gente no
quiere ver este papel creciente de China
y sigue obnubilada por la visión del
imperialismo de injerencia de Estados
Unidos a lo largo del final del 19 y de
hasta los años digamos hasta los
acuerdos de paz de 87 en Centroamérica
es el momento de La retirada de Estados
Unidos de esta área volvemos en este
punto con Kendra Carrión Por qué la
hacen vestidas del régimen de Ortega
contra los opositores incomodan tanto
vamos a ampliar a otros países a ciertos
gobiernos latinoamericanos como el
mexicano en esta línea Nicaragua
constituye uno de los fracasos más
notorios del régimen de defensa de la
Democracia por dos motivos el primero
tiene que ver con la habilidad de Daniel
Ortega de instrumentalizar los los
mecanismos de la oea para la defensa de
la Democracia que son el diálogo
político y la observación electoral en
segundo lugar a pesar de que a partir de
2018 cuando iniciaron las acciones
represivas del régimen varios países de
la región condenaron la situación en el
país centroamericano actores clave para
la activación de la carta democrática
Interamericana como México o argentina
se decantaron por guardar silencio y
abstenerse en varias de las resoluciones
clave de la oea en el caso de México
esto tiene que ver con su tradición en
materia de política exterior de no
intervención en los asuntos de internos
de otros países recordemos que
Argentina y México emitieron un
comunicado conjunto
reconociendo su preocupación por la
crisis en materia de Derechos Humanos en
Nicaragua apenas en 2021 esto también
responde a lo que yo denomino columpio
ide que hemos visto en América Latina a
lo largo del Siglo 21 el compromiso
regional con la defensa de la Democracia
ha develado más un carácter ideológico
que un trabajo objetivo de países que
realmente hayan interiorizado a la
democracia como un valor unas últimas
ideas que me quedo sin tiempo Pascal
Daniel no no olvidemos la consecuencia
también de la pandemia porque
Centroamérica con una población
más o menos con 60% de los activos que
dependen del sector informal ha tenido
consecuencias sociales económicas
políticas en percepción de eficacia
pública y no no lo olvidemos tampoco me
queda sin tiempo para más les agradezco
muchísimo haber compartido este tiempo
de radio y televisión con nosotros en
Primera Plana Muchas gracias Gil Pascal
Daniel y Kendra y a todos ustedes les
esperamos aquí en Primera Plana la
próxima semana Muchas gracias
[Música]